foreign
s of migrants lining up every day hoping
to cross into the U.S border officials
now warning and even greater surges
coming tonight facilities along the
southern border are being stretched to
the breaking point because of an
increase in migrants from Central
America stock between competing
immigration policies and squarely in the
middle of a humanitarian crisis border
communities try to balance the needs of
residents and of migrants coming to the
United States
policies need to be changed when you see
an unprecedented amount of people coming
across the border that even supersedes
what we saw under any of the other
presidents for the past 30 years and now
we're looking at 171 percent increase
this year this time over last year
that's ridiculous
and they're coming because they said
that Biden told them to come but we have
an open border
the problem that we're we're seeing
right now is there's a couple big waves
coming
and
the last couple weeks it's been 1300
people a day coming into Yuma when they
can only process about 800 a day so
they're close to 500 people over
capacity so what I've been told is
pretty soon they're going to start
releasing people out the front door into
the streets of Yuma
and Yuma can't support that you get 500
people a day coming into Yuma
overwhelm the system here
you would see trucks parked here
watching you don't see any of those
they're all processing people
border patrol can't man
the checkpoints on the highway where
they used to for the last two years they
haven't been open they used to stop you
know check for drugs coming out of
coming across the border so those aren't
open
when this initial Flow came through yeah
the food bank was tapped our economy is
based on a couple of things our security
around food and our food production
because we Supply uh 93 percent of the
leafy green vegetables for the United
States and Canada during the winter
we've gotten a fair amount of traffic
through
and around our Fields our fields are
monitored and audited and and tested you
know for different pathogens and you
can't have people walking through the
field
with emergency right now because of
cobit because of RSV and because of the
the flu generally people have had a hard
time getting into the hospital with
because the hospital has been so full of
illegals
until we have control of the Border we
cannot stop all of the other problems
and we can't even begin to address them
I don't see
I don't see how this is uh beneficial to
our country I can't see it it doesn't
seem the same as it has in the past it's
just it seems like
it's just the system is overwhelmed and
it's like we have everybody has a cell
phone now and they call and they're like
Get over now it's open come on down you
know they're handing out cell phones
Mr President
really easy just
put the containers back maybe come down
here come to the act like it's important
we had the border under control before
you got here
why don't you do what was done before to
get it back to that point
for sure the message has been sent that
the borders open and they're not turning
people back for sure the message is out
that border Patrol's overwhelmed and
now's the time to do it
it will only get worse
Biden's policies he needs to reassess
I've had commitments from well over 40
of those congressmen that have visited
here over the last year that they would
address this and specifically hold the
administration's feet to the fire in
addressing some of the challenges here
this is a different animal and you have
different concerns in El Paso they don't
necessarily have military and
agriculture directly bumping up against
the Border or these other smaller
communities where people have come
through and caused problems and
challenges I've invited them several
times and I would invite them again
right now
every time I have the opportunity to
talk about it I extend that invitation
please come and see for yourself